and joining me here on the rich eisen
show his show wipeout
airs tonight and every thursday at 9
eastern on
tbs along with nicole byer it is just
something that my kids cannot get enough
of as is much of this man's work
thrilled to have here on the rich eisen
show the great john cena how are you
john
thank you very much for the kind words
it is true i told you my kids are
jealous they might
they might burst in this room at any
point in time and want to
ask you a million questions that's fair
nowadays with the way things are i don't
put it past anything that's fair
so how did you how did you get involved
with wipeout why why get involved with
wipeout for you
uh well i love hosting um i've i've
hosted some
various various programs i've done
competition shows
i had a brief stand on the today show uh
i i did the espys
yes um i really do enjoy hosting
uh whether it's been in front of a live
audience or in game show format
and when wipeout came to me and said
well we want to reboot wipe out and we'd
like you and nicole to be the hosts
not only did i want to host again but i
was immediately drawn to the possibility
of our chemistry
nicole is extremely funny uh we play
opposite each other very well
yes and i think it would have been a
great fit and i know that the show has
such a long-standing history of
delivering to its fan
base it's something i really wanted to
be a part of yeah nicole
is a is again she's another big one with
my kids in the household with nailed it
yeah um and and there's there is kind of
sort of a hot mess element to wipe out
the same thing is nailed it uh you know
so it's kind of
these kind of marry into one another i
would say you also get
you also get two people that are
passionate about hosting and have
experience in hosting and i think that's
that's important uh
knowing what what their job is as a
vehicle to move the show
the show is about the course the show is
about the contestants and
the show is about the wipeouts and we
kind of are the orchestrators keeping
people moving from a to b and she
she understands that she knows that
she's the ultimate professional and like
i said it's a pleasure to work with her
so what do you like about hosting
uh you know i just you get
you get to hear people's story yeah you
know it's it's showcasing people's story
whether it's doing a competition show
or reading the news or being being a
vehicle to take you from
from a to b on an awards show you you
basically get to listen and learn
you know and i really do enjoy that i
enjoy uh i think it comes from
probably a it's deeply rooted in my
passion for watching
and listening to crowds in the wwe even
when i'm in the middle of the ring i'm
always watching and i'm always listening
and i like to
listen to that energy and i like to
learn about people and
of course seeing people wipe out not too
bad either not too bad either you know
and
uh god bless you for saying what you say
about hosting john cena you know i've
i've been fortunate to be
a host certainly from sportscenter or
now obviously to what i've been doing
nfl network in my daily show i mean i'll
show it to you
that roof right there over my head
that's that's hosting right there that's
that's that's that's what i do and and
these days you know like the the emmys
or the oscars went hostless and i've i
you know i'm
hosts are people too john is that's what
i'm saying to you you know hosts are
people too and
shows need someone to to do what you're
talking about
i couldn't agree more and not only that
i think it also
uh i think it's a very important
position like uh the conductor of an
orchestra still the the people in the
orchestra provide the music but the
conductor moves it from a to b
the host does the same thing and i
i really hope it gets back to host
driven things i mean we're going on a
bit of a tangent here
but that's i don't i don't i mean i
enjoy hosting and i'm sure there's
people like you
like me out there that enjoy doing that
and that takes the spot away from
their their ability to put a roof over
their head no i mean look
this is this is something that's uh uh
you know near and dear to my heart
that's why i'm i'm the one who's taking
us down this sort of blind alley right
now during
down hosting john just as soon as you
said like i love hosting i'm like god
bless you
um you know i i wish i also uh had the
resume like you where i could have uh
you know main evented wrestlemania five
times you know what i mean i i
uh you're too kind of putting it all
together and
i want i want to get to that in a second
uh but one one thing i wanted to bring
up to you
also um you know so many people
uh from you know the film train wreck
will say that lebron was the breakout
star of that film
uh but i would say you know
you were in that film sir you know like
that that
that i would say i would say your
assessment is correct i was in that film
and you were a breakout star in that
film
john i mean where you were
dynamite i mean literally every word out
of your mouth
was hilarious but i'm wondering how
that role was pitched to you and why you
jumped
headfirst into something like totally
out of your lane like that
well i mean i i think they say timing is
everything
and this was just a case of a lot of
luck and good timing
and amy schumer was putting together
their
movie loosely based on her life she had
had an episode with someone super
athletic
and it was right around the time that i
was i was kind of doing
all this hosting stuff and i was a known
name in wwe
and uh judd and amy had asked me to come
in for an audition
and the part was originally written to
just be a depiction of an overly
athletic
sex scene where she was like i'm over
this guy because it's it's too much work
and then when we got to sit in a room i
got to sit in a room with amy schumer
with judd behind a camera and just rip
and matt was like i just i didn't care
about not being cool i didn't care about
my jokes bombing
i just was myself and they enjoyed it so
much so that that
judd and amy both expanded the role they
um they changed the whole dynamic of the
relationship and
i got a a few seconds to be uh
you know to to kind of do my thing on
screen and i'll i'll never forget that
it literally was their idea
and um them providing an environment for
me to be
okay being stupid you know that's that's
that's a
comedy and especially with that just
those two names that's a very
very intimidating environment but i
finally just said effort i'm just gonna
i mean this is an opportunity that i
don't get
you know i did a bunch of karate action
movies in the early 2000's it didn't
amount to anything and i did it for the
wrong reasons
this was a part that i loved these are
people that i really idolized and
had a chance to work under and learn
from so i just said uh whatever i'll do
it
they're only going to air the good stuff
anyway so i'll just leave a bunch of
stuff in the cutting room before
and it was dynamite i mean literally
every word out of your mouth was laugh
out loud hilarious john
and big time no no question about it
do you have any good lebron stories did
you ever cross paths with women
never crossed pounds on set i really
wish we had um but
we never did so i mean he went on to do
some pretty great things after that film
so he i mean he did do okay
yeah i know i think he i think it all
worked out for everybody john i'll be
honest with you yeah i think you know i
think it's
i think it's a big plus you know i'll be
honest with you for everybody john cena
here
uh on the rich eisen show uh right here
on nbc sports on peacock i got the
peacock
label right behind me that's the home of
wrestlemania this weekend
what is what is your favorite
wrestlemania
memory john cena what do you got for uh
i think it would have to be
um hulk hogan versus under the giant
wrestlemania 3
because that was that was one that we
watched in home
and you know 93 000 in the silver dome i
think that put sports entertainment
on a map where you couldn't avoid it and
for years sports entertainment would
continue to define themselves it
continues to
as the company continues its its global
outreach but
that moment that moment in time you know
selling out madison squadron garden for
one and then multiple locations for two
both on
this new concept called closed circuit
television
and then three was in your home you
could buy it pay-per-view with the
advent of
a new technology called pay-per-view and
now we talk about uh
you know wrestlemania this weekend
streaming on peacock
um for me that that was the moment and
and i've never lost
the passion and the excitement that i
had as a child watching that match
and a lot of um really seasoned sports
entertainment or wwe fans will go back
through that card
and pick out randy savage and ricky
steamboat and
other other moments and matches to be
like well this one stole the show
for me that is that is the moment that i
was hooked without a doubt absolutely
hooked on sports entertainment
so what about one involving you though
john one of your
oh man i don't remember any of them
[Laughter]
yeah they tell me they've they've been
okay so that's the best i can do with
that but yeah
what's he used to remember in your own
stuff i mean
um i think it's i think it's the
unexpected moments
um matches for a united states title
when i was
uh over a decade into my career where
not too many people not only probably
would have
accepted that but accepted it with such
enthusiasm being a fan
i um i got to be a fan at one of the
wrestlemanias i got to have
you know two or three beers with
everybody in my section and watch
hours of the show before the undertaker
arrived at the building and i jumped
over the rail to change into the
superman outfit and come out and get my
ass kicked
but like stuff like that um
the the stories at the pinnacle of the
event
are the foundation is laid so long in
advance
and it's already there they're already
interested and i think it's those
obscure stories that i i really
take the most away from because nobody
expects a lot from them but it also
gives you the freedom
to kind of have some fun and do what you
want when was the first time you
realized you had arrived
john it was the first time like you know
when i rise second
i realize i've arrived that means the
ship has sailed
interesting i guess i still haven't got
there yet you still
yeah you're afraid of whitewater you
guys just making right turns
look kids big ben parliament i cannot
get left
you're still you're still that you're
you're afraid of a wipeout which
basically is what you're yeah you could
get wiped out anyway
i think if the second you arrive you
wipe out so well i mean i guess it's
for as a as a uh they see that's i'm
just trying to
keep up with you and my hosting skills
john i'm just trying to
i'm trying to stay one step ahead you're
that object
that's close in my rear view mirror
that's much larger than it appears
and and you know what i mean i'm i'm i'm
i gotta i gotta
i got i gotta do it you know what i mean
i gotta bring my a game
with you john cena you know what i mean
so but when you so when you
i guess in the wwe world was it meeting
somebody was it a conversation was it a
moment in the ring where
you felt like okay i belong how does
that sound where you feel like now that
you arrived but you belonged
in your journey at all uh i think i
think the second i was given
my first low-level contract which was in
2000
you know that's a them betting on you is
a
is it is a certificate saying like you
belong here right sign your name and
you're into the you're invited into the
group
it's a you know um a prospect making it
to the majors
like your path is still to be crafted
and your choices and and your effort and
your
you know your representation against
your peers will determine your success
but if you make it to the company you
want to work for or the the
the the league you want to be in like
the
you know you you've made it to that you
know that's
the rest is just we'll see we'll see
where it goes well again congrats on
on everything that's going on in your
life and your your career john
and uh mike honestly my kids when
the new season of wipeout was coming out
and it was you and nicole buyer
it was appointment television like
literally it's and it's so rare
i've got a 12 a 10 and a seven for them
to agree on
anything and let alone sit there quietly
hands to themselves putting their
screens down to watch
something i do appreciate that and i
will say and proudly
like uh you're not alone we had a really
great debut or the number one show on
cable and uh
cbs is rocking on thursday nights so i
it really means a lot to me
uh growing up with a house of five
brothers and before the advent of
screens we could never get along on
anything and the one thing that brought
us together was wwe
so to hear that you could enjoy a moment
with your family of various ages
whatever was the nucleus for that is
awesome but the fact that it was wiped
out is really something special as well
the issue is john and maybe you can help
me with this too is what happens when
they want to play wipe
out themselves with just odd things
around the house
once you're off the air what happens
then i mean
i know i'm asking for a parenting
question here simple message from wwe
always comes to mind yes
don't try this at home
[Laughter]
do not it's a simple disclaimer it it
don't try this at home it crosses so
many lines um
so again thursday nights uh every
thursday night not eastern on tbs
wipeout
uh john uh like i said um a big fan and
i hope
we get to continue to do this again any
time on this show and uh obviously we'll
be
thinking of this weekend watching uh
wrestlemania on peacock and
and then wipe out after that thanks
thank you very much i look forward to
talking in the future
right back at you okay that is john cena
coming for my job and every other host
job
uh including everybody look out there it
is
uh right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here